what streaming and cable did just last
year okay last year July of 2022 was a
very historic month here's why that was
the month we're officially streaming Rob
if you can go back on the screen that
was the month where streaming passed up
okay no no you go back where you are
you're good I'm just saying put your
mouse on the yeah you're right there
that is the month where streaming passed
up cable
so if you look at cable it was going
down uh this is a two-year chart from 21
to 22 it went down it went down and went
down so boom it hits 34.4 percent and
streaming goes up to 34.8 percent now
before you go to the other one let's
stay here A year later
to see where streaming goes and where
cable drops how big of a difference
would you think would happen just one
year if you go to the next charge that
the chart that the reports just came out
with is the following when you go here
you now see streaming went to 38.7 so
the lead they had was only 0.4 percent
they go to 38.7 and cable drops to 30
29.6 what's the difference there roughly
9.1 the separation in one year that
means you're going from you know first
quarter to second quarter you got a you
know touchdown lead all of a sudden you
got a 3-4 touchdown lead in one quarter
boom so this goes to 38.7 at the top as
well YouTube Netflix Hulu Prime Disney
max 2B peacock Roku all that stuff right
cable getting crushed however what is
keeping cable what happened no nothing
yeah what what keeps what's keeping
Cable in business so watch
Rob do me a favor uh before we go to
this I want you to think about this
three things we're talking to our guys
here yesterday uh shout out to uh
Brandon Kelly and Elon phenomenal
conversation we're having with these
guys
and here's what we saw the number one
thing that the three things that are
keeping Cable in business first thing is
all folks listening watching TV okay
they just want to go home and watch Fox
CNN MSNBC that's kind of how they get
their news no problem okay and there's a
timeline to that you know I'm 44 years
old I'm not living forever okay so old
folks are not going to be around forever
when they're watching what they're
watching number two is sports okay so
cable for the longest time has always
had Sports football soccer baseball you
know basketball we watch NBA on yeah
we watch we consume Sports so what's
happening with sports lately sports
teams are now saying I'm gonna do it
myself and not only that streaming
companies are now offering money to who
Sports deals and saying hey bring the
NFL to us we're Amazon bring this to us
so Cable's like wait a minute wait a
minute we thought our only competition
was DirecTV and now DirecTV is running
out of money but you guys can't pick
this up to streaming why would anybody
want to watch streaming and Tom who one
day said I said dude I gotta watch this
game Tom how am I going to be able to
watch this game and says Pat go on Hulu
you can watch the baseball game on any
funnel so what are you talking about I'm
younger than Tom but when it comes to
technology Tom's young gonna meet yeah
so I'm like Tom show me how to do this I
go home I'm like are you kidding me you
mean to tell me I can watch your game I
said yeah Pat just watch it here I
remember this conversation you and I had
because cable went out in your
neighborhood yeah because cable went out
of my neighborhood oh yeah so I'm
watching this I'm like sick on your
phone and your iPad at HD but but this
is the last one let me tell you what the
last one is
I want to ask this question you guys all
know the answer to this question except
for Rob all right we had dinner last
night and we had a good conversation
about this folks if you're watching this
what percentage of cable TV
do you think
their advertisement comes from Big
Pharma what percentage Rob I'm actually
curious enough for people to answer this
and you want Rob to know too don't look
it up I want you to guess what what do
you think the number is what percentage
of cable TV advertisement you think
comes from Big Pharma I'd like to see
what the chat has to say as well they
Googled it already they got the answers
you had to randomly guess what to say
above 60 so 60 to 70 go Google it now
and see what percentage of advertisement
money for cable comes from Big Pharma
wow and and wait till I drop this on you
on on what do you think is going to
happen here next if you can pull this up
uh uh what's the number
75 percent wrong oh my God 75 life and
this is as of two months ago drug dealer
May 11 2023 is the article 75 is coming
from drug companies Pharma so check this
out let me break you to the cable folks
that are given all these big ass
contracts to people like ESPN and fox
and CNN and ABC and a lot of these guys
to be honest with you good for them for
getting their money but they're getting
overpaid because they would have never
made that kind of money in the
podcasting game podcasting is hard cable
is easier because you're going to have a
script to read teleprompter 50 people
handing you a piece of paper and
research and 17 facts on a piece of
paper you don't have that one you're
independent this is one when you see a
guy like Joe Rogan kicking everyone's
ass he doesn't have a research team when
he go to his office you know what it is
it's him and another guy that's built a
number one show and all these other
podcasts you watching what the hell are
these guys doing moral of the story
here's a moral of the story that's
getting me fired up you ready for this
I'm ready you ready for this let's go
hey
if
you talk to any presidential candidate
not that I'm going to be talking to any
of them but if we do you never know just
throwing it out there you know what the
question and the commitment we have
here's the question I want to get from
them
hey Mr presidential candidate yes
um out of nearly 200 countries worldwide
only two of them allow for big Pharma to
advertise which what are those it's New
Zealand and United States interesting
which is kind of strange and a lot of
American people are starting to ask the
question why is it that only one percent
of countries in the world allow for
pharmaceutical companies to advertise Us
in New Zealand are you trying to save
folks in Japan are dumb are you trying
to say folks in Germany are dumb or
Mexico or Canada or even some of these
socialist companies that you would buy
countries that you admire Venezuela you
know how about China why don't they
allow big Pharma to advertise isn't it
deeply concerning to you well it is
what if moving forward are you willing
to agree as a president that if you
become a president you will no longer
allow big Pharma to advertise on cable
TV and if this candidate there's one
candidate that I know four fact would
say yes and he'd run with it you know
what his name is his initials are
okay do you know what happens if Trump
runs with this let me break it down for
you if 75 of cable is getting their
money from Big Pharma and they all
supported vaccine and they all supported
us taking the vaccine over and over and
over and over again
they said moving forward you can no
longer do it especially you know why
this could happen today because this
happened after covet and people don't
trust Pharma today they don't trust CDC
today they don't trust the government
today and they don't trust the
mainstream media today the lowest it's
ever been they don't trust it today if
the president said you know what moving
forward guess what we're not doing this
no more big pharma's out this means 75
of mainstream media companies are gone
overnight wow overnight CBS ABC NBC CNN
ESPN CNN Fox go to Fox commercials MSNBC
their budget is gone so these guys that
they're able to pay them all this money
they're not paying them the money
Pfizer's paying them the money all these
big in pharmaceutical companies are
paying them now that they're not getting
the money they're going to go to the
talent and say listen man another
opinion six million dollars we kind of
got to bring that to one and a half
million what six million is what I've
been getting paid I've been living in
this 10 million dollar house you want me
to get out of this house we can't pay
you that anymore bro we can't I'm going
to leave
then it's gonna be well go leave
where am I going to go I'm gonna go to
CBS they also have the same problem I'm
going to call NBC they also have this
let me call my manager I'm going to call
my managers from WME hey Johnny he was
laid off yeah
so so so the moral of the story here is
all of this stuff that's going on uh
you're going to see what it's going to
go down to here's what it's going to go
down to it's going to go down to who can
sell who can perform who can get
eyeballs who can get subscribers who can
keep creating content that's exciting
sexy interesting who keeps recreating
themselves because those who don't this
dinosaur caveman model of how the Medias
ran protected by big Pharma will be
destroyed overnight if a courageous
president has the brass to say moving
forward big farmer can no longer
advertise so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here